all right am i the a-hole i don't think
i need to introduce this segment we've
done it before i think i think you
basically understand how this works and
this is going to be like uh many of the
other videos we've done where we go to
the mi the a-hole forum on reddit except
we're switching things up it's very
exciting this time um because we're
going to do that except this time i'm in
a more comfortable chair so we like to
keep things fresh
here on the matt wall show we'll start
with this my two daughters are
vegetarian but my husband and son are
not i'm probably what they would call a
flexitarian well you're definitely the
apple i already know that you're the
[ __ ] based on that alone a
flexitarian so what does that mean
you're like you're flexible you'll eat
meat or vegetables is that what you mean
by flex so you're just a person you're a
normal person like all the rest of us
you don't need to call with new labels
for everything you're not it's not you
didn't invent something new i'm a
fooditarian you know because i
uh my my thing is that i i eat food you
know i don't if it's not food i don't
eat it i'm a walk on the ground itarian
you know as i i generally i only walk on
things that are the ground
anyway
where were you my son and husband always
turn up their noses at tofu or any other
meat alternatives they say it's just
weird that it's made to resemble real
meat so it's really the concept and not
the taste
there are no allergies my family and i
often make two versions of dinner one
meat one reel and twice the amount of
pots and pans there is an equal
distribution of cleaning and cooking in
this house thankfully my daughters had a
fun prank idea of making two pots of
spaghetti sauce under the pretense that
one was meat but they were both the soy
ground beef
the goal here was to see if their
brother and father actually hated the
meat that is the fake meat and to see if
we could maybe save some dishes and time
in the future
everyone loved dinner both husband and
son finished their plates this was when
my youngest couldn't hold it in anymore
and told them they both got very upset
about being fed something other than
what they were told
reddit am i the [ __ ] so
they made soy soy meat which is not
that's like that's that doesn't actually
exist just like when they
when you hear about coconut milk or
almond milk that's not actually milk
milk by definition is a dairy product
that's a coconut secretion is what i
should say on the carton there's no such
thing as soy meat that's just it's fake
so they made a soy thing
in two pots and they said that one was
meat and they said that they were
feeding that to the husband and son but
it was really the soy and they couldn't
tell the difference
now reddit has declared that this woman
is the old yes you are the a-hole
oh
goodbye you should never lie to somebody
about what you're feeding them so that
makes you an a-hole but
i actually think you're an a-hole for a
different reason you expect me to
believe
that you made a meat sauce
with soy beef and then your son and
husband
who are big long time meat eaters they
couldn't tell that it wasn't real meat
that's [ __ ] sorry i just i don't
believe it that's gorgeous
total gorgonz i've had meat substitutes
before
just purely out of morbid curiosity and
they they always taste like
fertilizer and sadness what does it
taste like despair okay they taste
fraudulent
always and by the way if you have an
ethical problem with meat
then why are you eating food made to
taste like it that's the other thing i
don't understand i have a problem with
this i don't want to eat meat i think
it's immoral but i want my food to taste
like the thing that's immoral it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to me well
let me ask you something what if there
was someone out there who kept the log
of every single thing you did every
minute of the day i think that'd be
pretty creepy well what if i told you
that's exactly what happens every time
you go online your internet provider
like at t or comcast is allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited and they can legally sell this
data to anyone they want that's why i
always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you're doing online now many of you if
you're more perceptive you might be
wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn then doesn't the vpn
get to log and see all my data and
you're right to think that way many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy but have
been caught logging customer activity
anyway expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com
walsh yt right now and find out how you
can get three months free okay um
next one i live alone in a one-bedroom
apartment recently a co-worker let's
call them ally has been coming to my
supervisor to talk and visit almost
every shift
they've been talking about how ali has
had a downturn in job performance and
might be laid off soon if things don't
improve
ali is nice and outgoing but not
reliable when it comes to office work
the past couple of days my supervisor
has been very interested in my living
situation
always asking how the area is how i
decorate my space how my relationship is
with the property manager
they've even started making comments
about how lucky i am to live alone and
how important community is yesterday
after hours
we just get to the point here how would
we don't we don't you don't need to go
back five years in the story just get to
the freaking point
um
okay for over a half an hour they went
on and on about how i could let her live
with me and how good it would be to
carpool split expenses and have company
at home i tried to keep the shocked okay
so basically your supervisor is
pressuring you to have a co-worker move
in with you as a roommate you could have
just said that the whole rest of the
story is not necessary we don't need to
know what you had for breakfast that
morning am i the a-hole
well no i mean you're the a-hole for
telling this long boring story but not
in this particular situation
i hear these stories from people's jobs
sometimes and just like what
first of all why would you tolerate this
to begin with your supervisor at your
job is trying to force you to
to
to allow another person at your job to
live with you i don't know if this is
appropriate
it's wildly inappropriate and it's
definitely illegal in like 50 000
different ways
so first thing i would do is go and get
that supervisor fired
and then absolutely you do not let this
person move in with you though this is
coming from someone who i would never
let anyone move in with me as a roommate
i think the whole concept of roommates
to me just doesn't make any sense if
you're getting married and you're
starting a family right with someone
that's one thing that's not really a
roommate you get none of the benefit of
starting a family yet you get all of the
annoyances of having to live with other
people in your house part of the problem
and i don't no offense to meant by this
but
it seems to be mostly women who use the
mida whole forum on reddit and this is
something women do and look ladies you
have to realize that you do this you
know if you have information that you
want to pass on to someone you you
always start way further back in the
timeline than you need to that's the
scourge of of of existence for women
you're always complaining oh you know
the man they don't remember they don't
listen it's because you're giving us way
too much information okay and that's not
how our minds work we can't retain all
that we we're we're looking for the
we're looking for the point and that's
where we home in
and that's gonna do it okay let's stop
now
[Music]